So, Marvel Rivals just came out.
The newest, hit craze, third-person shooter game.
And, because it just came out, Top 500 at the time was just plat.
So, there was no eternity player yet.
There was no one above all.
Everybody had to start from zero.
So, I decided to challenge myself and see how fast I could get to Top 500.
Surprisingly, it didn't take that long.
It took me three days of just playing Link to get to Top 500.
In the world, by the way.
This is a global leaderboard.
By the way, I was the very first VTuber to hit it, too.
How did I do it?
Well, it's time for you to keep watching to find out.
Hello!
We're back with Marvel Rivals because I am this close to Top 500.
I mean, I'm platinum three.
With, like, 6.6 hours of gameplay.
And you're like, plat, that's not good.
Well, plat one is the cutoff for Top 500, might I add.
And, not only that, this is a global leaderboard.
So, it's not just NA.
So, I am this close to get Top 500.
I'm really proud of myself to be able to get this close to Top 500.
With my incredibly fucking busy hours.
But, yeah, I've been, like, super addicted to Marvel Rivals.
Only because, like, whenever a new shiny competitive game comes out, I speedrun to the leaderboards.
And then after getting it, I stop.
So, like, I might try and end Top 500 in Marvel Rivals.
Because after I get it, I just don't care about it anymore.
Because that's how it usually goes.
Like...
Alright, I'm ready to focus up.
I gotta make sure our Hela is having a good time.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll just save people.
Come on, guys!
Let's go!
Have fun!
Do your DPS!
Let's go!
Okay, I need to heal you, though.
Do your thing!
Let's go!
Oh, shit.
Survive!
I'm healing!
I'm a support!
Let's go, guys!
I'm a one-trick!
Like, everything I learned from Luna Snow is just me learning it myself.
I don't actually know how to play her that optimally.
So, like, I won't watch, like, an actual pro player.
Like, I basically self-taught myself Luna Snow since Alpha.
So, like, I don't know how to actually play her optimally.
Stop.
Stop feeding.
The fuck are you doing?
Stop.
Please!
All you have to do is stop!
Oh, they got him!
They got him!
We did it!
Yeah!
That's right.
Fuck you, Margo!
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll do Jeff.
I'm Kat.
I'm weak.
I'm so weak.
It's okay.
If we lose, it's her fault.
Not my fault.
Because she wouldn't let me play my one-trick.
Jesus.
Yes!
Do something!
I'm reloading my mouse!
I'm going in.
Oh, they're scared.
They're so scared.
I got their support too.
Easy.
Alright, I'm gonna avoid Margo because she's a one-trick too.
I can't help.
That became the one thing I hated the most.
Goddamn.
One-trick was the silver.
No!
Oh no.
It's time for Jeff, I guess.
Oh my god.
Do we have like three Luna players?
This is bad.
We have too many Luna players.
Why do we have so many support players?
No!
There we go.
I was hoping to kill him.
Okay.
Sorry, I have to kill.
Sorry, I have to work on killing the Hawkeye.
I'm sorry, I couldn't help you, bro.
I'm gonna swap.
Alright, let's try it.
Let's learn her live.
We're gonna learn her live.
I don't know how to play her, but we're gonna...
Oh, but at least we get to look at something nice, I guess.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh my god.
How?
Okay, we gotta go in, though.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, I'm just...
Alright.
Come on, let's go in, guys.
Let's...
Okay, I...
Okay, I died so fast in my ult.
Wait, we had three ults?
What happened?
Gotta avoid all the Luna snow.
This is a detriment to me.
Yeah, everybody stop playing Luna.
She's actually trash.
But I make her look good, guys.
There we go.
Oh!
What?
Oh my god!
I was so dumb!
That was actually bullshit!
Alright.
Of course, it's me and Sharma.
We were both not paying attention because I was so dumb.
Because we were fucking streaming.
I had to penny the door.
I was like, I don't give a fuck.
I'm not sure for it.
I was like, what the fuck was that sound?
Holy fuck!
I just...
Oh my god!
What did I do?
Shit, there's Hawkeye.
There's...
There's Hawkeye's ult.
Oh no!
That's all of us!
I heard it!
I heard the...
I
don't...
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
I don't need to use it yet.
There's no reason to.
No!
You can't eat me!
I had to!
I fucking had to!
That was the only way to live.
I ulted to live.
I actually ulted to live there.
I'm so hungry.
So hungry.
Alright, I think I froze somebody.
Yeah, I did.
Oh shit!
Ah, bitch.
That's fucking right.
Be afraid of me.
I am a Luna Snow that can fucking aim.
I need to do this for the stronger heals.
Oh my god!
Be afraid!
That's fucking right.
Oh, the cat.
That's so toxic!
Easy.
Yay!
One more rank, guys!
One more rank up!
Oh my god, I'm doing it!
Plat 2!
Yes, it's still Plat 1.
Oh my god, we're so close.
Oh my god, we're so close!
Bro, bro, I'm trying so hard!
Oh my god, you're alive!
Guys, did you see how they lined up for the clap?
Holy fuck!
That was like the perfect lineup.
Oh my god, it literally hit everybody.
Nice, we got...
Wow, you're alive!
How'd he...
My fucking gamer!
How the fuck...
He was not supposed to live.
We recreated the movie.
I think I'm gonna go for...
I'm gonna go for Plat 1 and then I'm gonna call it.
Because then I don't have to like speedrun anymore.
I'm only speedrunning because I want to touch the leaderboard.
And just to be like, hey guys.
Haha, look at this.
Um...
Liv...
Oh my...
How much damage are you taking?
Oh my god!
He's Groot.
No, no.
Oh, thank god.
I'm trying!
Guys!
Oh my god!
That's Jeff!
I was like, where did he come from?
I should eventually hit him, right?
There's like a clusterfuck of people there.
I'm just shooting in the general direction, hoping I hit something.
Oh no, oh no!
I had to reload at that time!
We had three healers and all of you guys had to reload!
Warlock is good, but like, his heals are very limited.
I think Luna's better for sustainability.
I personally think after playing for this long, I think it's Luna, Mantis, and Cloak and Dagger.
I feel like are the best healers.
Nice.
Wait, me too.
I am also ready to put on a show.
Hey, me too!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh guys, calm the fuck down!
Guys.
There can't all be- We gotta calm down with all the shows, guys.
Jesus Christ, how did I live through all of that?
Holy shit, we're coming in with five ults.
Like, if we don't win this, this is like, we deserve to lose that round.
Like, we're literally coming in with like, six ults, five ults.
Alright, go in.
I like how he set up a turret there, he's like, this is it.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We almost didn't stand on point.
That would have been so fucking bad.
Guys!
You know what that means!
Let's put on a show!
Yeah!
Better than 99.93 for people in the world!
Wait!
No, I'm so close!
I'm so close!
Oh my god, I'm so close.
It's like, right there.
Yeah!
Oh my god, three more wins.
We just need three more wins.
Oh my god, surely I'll win three in a row, right?
Surely, I'll win three in a row, right?
Surely, right?
Oh my god.
I'm stuck in this loop.
No!
There's
no fucking way.
There's no fucking way.
I am losing it.
I am 100% losing it right now.
Please.
Oh my god.
Like, what?
I went through hell.
I'm a better fucking player than all of you.
Like, I built my character.
Okay, like, I don't...
I can't fucking save you there.
Like, Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I don't know what you want from me.
I don't...
I'm dead.
I gotta save my fucking KD.
Did I heard that correctly?
We were losing so hard.
And then finally, when we had a chance to win, our Dr. Strange got stuck under the map and we were 5v6.
Curse of Ra worked.
Where's my heals?
Oh, what do you mean?
You had an orb.
Where's my heals at?
You had an entire orb.
Alright, goodbye.
Oh my god.
I guess I die.
I'm dead.
Everything is fine.
The panther is low.
I'm not fine.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you so want to see me, bitch.
I have the power of god on my side.
Go, fucking fight.
Go.
I'm scared.
I so wanted to save you.
I'm out of this bitch.
You better kill somebody.
Oh my god.
The whole team is here.
I can't do shit.
We're here.
I can't believe you didn't kill anyone.
I can't believe.
I'm putting on a show as well.
Watch me dance.
I'm beating the shit out of this mantis.
Do it.
Where was my lunar ult at?
You were definitely not on it.
You were definitely not on the lunar ult.
That's for sure.
I might be dead though.
Oh my.
No.
Oh my god.
Jeff, where's Jeff?
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I knew I should have fucking trusted only myself.
What?
And he jumps off.
Of course, this fucker.
I have no support.
Don't fucking get me.
Let me not get this.
Stop.
Because there's a...
Oh no, not that ult.
I can't.
I'm catching you.
We see nine.
Guys, I think I deranked to plat 3 from that.
I think I got deranked.
Alright, GG's though.
Those were fun games.
I hope you suffer.
What?
Why would you say that?
Because Curse of Ra and Loser's Key was funny.
That's... no, come on.
Alright, even though we didn't make it to top 500, we will try again tomorrow.
I really, really want to have... I'm desperate.
If we don't make it to top 500, I will replace all my streams with Marvel Rivals until we get top 500.
So you better hope that I fucking get top 500 today.
You think I fucking care?
I care about numbers.
I care about being a top 500 gamer right now.
We have Wanted and SK playing with me.
At least, like, I'll actually have DPS players this time.
Because for some fucking reason, every other player are getting too many DPS players.
But I have the opposite of that problem.
I have too many support players.
So, to fix that problem, now I have two DPS players.
I'd rather have too many DPS players.
Oh, okay.
Now that I said that.
You fucker.
We will damage boost.
We will out-damage all of this.
There's no way.
You actual fucker.
I will do a dance-off with you.
You think you're a better dancer than me?
I've been dancing for definitely more than 20 hours.
He's in my queue though.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
No, I also hate all spiders too.
I hate a lot of things.
I used to never hate a lot of things.
But after playing Marvel Rivals, I'm the hater now.
I'm definitely afraid of bugs.
I would fucking go outside and squish a spider.
For every time a Peter Parker annoys me.
Alright, run.
Run, you're such a bitch.
Alright, I'm going outside and squishing a spider.
Ashley, fuck you.
Okay, you gotta admit.
No!
If you watch like yesterday's stream versus today's stream.
You can tell I'm a different person now.
It only takes one really, really fucking bad day.
Her smile, her optimism.
Gone forever.
Oh my god, you're so not fine.
Oh my...
Oh, I actually got greeted by the fucking staircase.
I think this is one of the worst maps.
Honestly.
This is one of the worst maps.
This is...
This is actually one of the worst.
I hate all these stupid staircases.
But like...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Holy shit!
That portal was fucking insane!
That
was actually an insane portal.
But he didn't kill me.
He forgot about me.
That's right.
Fuck it!
Should've killed the fucking support.
That's Ashe's...
Oh my god, people are getting too good at this game, guys.
I need to get top 500 before people learn everything.
Oh, she's one!
Okay, nice.
That was an insane ice shot, though.
Holy...
Please get me in a plat one.
Please.
We just need one more win and I'll be plat one.
And then we need four wins and I'll be fucking diamond three.
Oh, wait.
No, I was...
Ah, I'm blocked!
Yay!
Okay, we need three wins.
Three wins and then I'll be top 500.
Please pray for me.
First with the same movies.
I'm not plat two.
I'm plat one.
I'm just peeking the stairs.
Oh my god!
Big viking tries to pound small woman.
There we go.
Don't worry, I saved your life.
No need to thank me.
There we go.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
We did it!
Yes!
We're 99.92% better than all of you.
We're out of the plat mine.
Two more games.
It's two more games.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
How?
Jesus.
How much damage are y'all taking?
I don't know.
Yes.
Oh my god, he also...
I hate this because I keep going back to the portal.
So it's like...
What?
Why?
Going back in.
Can't go back in.
Can't peek back in.
I don't want to peek back in.
I don't want to be there anymore.
Three more games.
Three more...
Oh, he got shielded!
That would have hit if he didn't get shielded.
Guys, four more games.
This is not looking good.
Yes!
Oh, not yes.
Not yes anymore.
No, not yes.
Guys.
No.
No, I just...
Fuck, he caught!
Guys.
No.
No!
He bumped me off the health pack!
Oh my god.
This hurts.
Put on the nose, Draver.
Put it on.
Put on the nose.
Guys.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck, that's so painful.
Oh no.
Oh no!
What?!
Actual sponge.
Do it again.
No.
No, not again!
How do we get back?
This is...
I need some...
I believe.
Nobody's getting damaged though.
That's fucking right.
When does it end?
No!
Oh crap.
No.
He has way too many notes.
No, it's over.
Yes, yes, we did it!
Oh my god, that's the last fight.
Oh my god.
Block it, block it, we did it!
Oh my god, we're actually free.
Don't think it's over.
For today.
And then my game crashed.
Do I get the points?
My game crashed just then.
Surely you get the points.
Do you want me to tell you if you got the points?
I didn't, did I?
I didn't get the points, right?
Toki, you got the points.
We're good.
Oh my god.
Top 500 is Diamond 2 now.
I'm gonna fucking...
We did it.
Diamond 3.
We can go to bed.
Diamond 2 is Top 500.
We're always just one rank away.
Hello, hello!
I think I played like almost 20 hours of Marvel Rivals the last two days on stream.
My brain is like mush right now.
By the way, if you use the code JOKIBERRY, you get 10% off.
I've been on Gamersubs this entire Marvel Rivals grind just to like lock in and stay awake.
Clearly the only reason I'm able to function right now.
Back to back.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
I don't feel fine no more.
I feel fine again.
I am so healthy.
We're dancing!
Cause we're dancing!
Dance your pain away!
You'll eventually get Top 500, JOKI, if you just keep dancing.
Nice, we did it!
Three games, chat.
Three fucking games.
Yes!
Two more fucking games!
And then only three.
It's fine.
Yay!
Oh my, is this it?
I need, oh my god.
One more game.
One more game, guys.
No again!
That's right!
Whoa, okay.
That's it.
That scared me, though.
Wait, is this it?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Beat him up!
I'm gonna fucking start fisting!
Fuck you!
Yes!
I win two!
Wait, is that it?
47!
No!
I need one more!
I hope we're lucky, guys.
I hope we're lucky.
I hope we can be lucky.
There's no plat players in here.
There's a grandmaster?!
Bro, why does the enemy team have a fucking grandmaster?!
He's rank 41?!
Of course my top 500 game has to be, like, the hardest game.
Both teams are stacked as fuck.
I'm just getting Iron Man in the back, so I gotta heal.
No, Iron Man will...
Stop him, stop him, stop him.
Maximum!
Okay, okay.
Nice.
I won.
We're dead.
Oh yeah.
They don't live.
Let me get in there.
Let me get back.
Like this.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh my god.
First Nunu ult.
Suck buddy.
No!
Oh.
Oh no!
I wasted it too.
Oh, I didn't think I'd get hit by that.
Oh.
Oh my god.
They all die so fast.
Oh!
He didn't stun him!
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm going up.
Woah!
Nice!
What is this?
Oh!
Alright, I'm going up.
Hulk is red.
Hulk one, Hulk one!
Nice.
I'm dead.
Do you have a Nunu ult though?
Do you have a Nunu ult?
Nice.
I'm not dabbing, I'm not dabbing.
Oh!
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Come back, come back.
I'm on, I'm on.
This side.
Starlord, Starlord.
He's low, he's low.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, is that it?
Is that it?
Oh my god.
Did we do it?
Is it over?
I don't know.
Is that it?
Yes!
Guys!
Grandmaster to get here.
I literally beat a Grandmaster to get my ELO.
And I played so well.
I played so fucking well.
And that's how I did it.
That's how I became the very first VTuber to touch Top 500 in the world for Marble Rivals.
Back then, that was Diamond Top 500.
Now, we're in One Above All.
So, the grind never stops.
Tune in next time to see how I become the very first VTuber to end in One Above All Top 500 for Marble Rivals Season 0.
And I played with the rank 1 player to get there.